I'm Patrick me David and today I want to
talk to you about an advice that was
given to the entire audience by Charles
Aznavour the famous Charles Aznavour at
a concert I was with last week with a
friend of mine if you don't know who
Charles Aznavour is the world knows who
this man is I mean this man is a legend
he was 90 years old when he performed
last week being one of the only if not
the only 90 year old that's ever
performed to an audience as large as it
was as at Greek theater he sold over 100
million records has composed over 1,000
songs 150 in English 100 in Italian I
believe 70 in Spanish 50 in German he's
been on 6 in 60 different movies he
wasn't that one movie with Mark Wahlberg
the truth about Charlie where he
performs CNN they wanted to talk about
that when I got a poll on the greatest
performer of the last century the great
greatest entertainer of the last century
according to CNN he won first place over
Elvis Presley and the Beatles as the
greatest performer of the last century
worldwide Charles Aznavour and what's
special about Charles Aznavour is he is
by far the most famous Armenian in the
world was born in France if you ask any
Armenian who knows Charles he is a hero
to every Armenian because of how much is
contributed to his country regularly
over the years now one time were twice
regularly to the point where they build
a statue of this man in in Armenia and
the reason why I want to do an episode
on him today is because he subtly set a
message at the concert that was so
emotional that I think everybody could
get value from it's on stage and he
wrote a song called my Judas when he
talks about a song towards all the Judas
of his life and you know Judah Judas in
in the Bible of the Tres and he says
when I was famous
everybody was next to me now
I'm no longer the young guy you know and
all these guys betrayed me and he talks
about yesterday I remember when I was
young any good that's a song everybody
needs to read the lyrics it's so
powerful I'm gonna add it in the
description for you to be able to read
the lyrics of yesterday when I was young
and he's 90 years old talking about he
would give anything to be sixty years
old again
so not amazing it's a 90 year old man
thinking he would give anything to be 60
again I know people who are 45 I think
they're already too old and I've thrown
in the towel here's a 90 year old man
that's on stage dancing singing no
brakes
he went straight to ours no brakes not
one break for five minutes
not one bird have you ever been to a
concert he didn't have one bathroom
break nobody did my friends wanted to go
to the bathroom he didn't need to go to
the bathroom at 90 years old and he
performed I can only imagine what a
conversation would be with someone like
that for one hour I would be so curious
to talk to him for one hour to get
wisdom from him because every time he
would sing I would just wait for the
break because he would give 15 second
advice about life so best advice from
Charles don't ever think it's too late
to have your dreams come true because to
a 90 year old Charles being 60 is very
young it's by message of the week to you
and please you should have subscribed to
this channel thank you for watching